talking about taking the bread away from
things let's talk about japanese
hamburgers or
hambagus yeah that's right it's like a
hamburger
it's a hamburger an abomination [ __ ]
love them because [ __ ] stuff
japanese hambagus it's literally just a
hamburger or like a burger
patty patty yeah without the bun
[Laughter]
because it's good i love it the best
part of a hamburger
and i am going to go one of those rants
again man it's like the pizza thing dude
it's the synergy
it's the synergy bro there is there is a
way to a burger
man it's like what it's all the
accumulation of the tastes
that come together and they strike
slightly moderately because
because like for like 90 of burgers
you don't give a [ __ ] about the synergy
you're there for the [ __ ] party
like you okay you have like a shirt you
have like a brioche bun with some
lettuce
tomatoes and some bacon it's [ __ ]
amazing but like
you get a mcdonald's burger who gives a
[ __ ] man oh no
i don't know mcdonald's burger has been
and more engineered than any burger in
the world
that thing has been scientifically
proven
that is why you will never say no to a
double cheeseburger at mcdonald's i
guarantee it
i do because it's got ketchup in it but
without
regardless of the point it's a [ __ ]
dry
ass patty like i don't give a [ __ ] about
that it is literally just
[ __ ] it is literal junk no i i love
my gourmet burgers dude i
love every kind of burger that's the
mcdonald's burger has it
that's that's that's why no matter what
hamburger you get you get a gourmet
patty or like
what would be like a gourmet patty on
like a gourmet burger yeah you you
always order the shitty patties though
in these places like you order like the
the shitty hamburger that was made in
the factory like probably like 10 miles
away
yeah like i said it's still 10 times
better than anything you order from
[ __ ] mcdonald's
i'm like burger king or like most burger
joints
you know what i mean i'm going to have
to agree with god
like don't get me wrong like you know
sometimes i'll wake up and just be like
like i'll never say no to a double
cheeseburger or a whopper right
on some days a whopper burger here is
great
yes i'll take it over any of those
sometimes you just you know sometimes
you're just like i just want to eat some
[ __ ] today but then other times you're
like
i really just want meat yeah i just want
a hamburger i just want the patties it's
just the patties
it's just the patty of a burger i just
want the patty in my eyes if you're
going to just
order a hamburger just like with veg and
maybe fries
just get a [ __ ] steak just like no no
no
[Music]
i will never eat a [ __ ] steak over a
hamburger never what
yeah i just don't i don't like
strawberries i will take the inferior
worst tasting
i don't like steak oh my god i think
steak is [ __ ] mid
no man okay okay okay okay
i think the steak is it's like eating
cardboard it's just a [ __ ] piece of
meat
like to me eating a hamburger right
what is going on eating
i'll let him freak out eating a
hamburger right is just like
it's like a kid's meal it doesn't look
right it looks like you're talking about
about it it's like oh oh you a little
god can't handle the tomatoes and the
bread oh we'll just take the burger out
for you oh
it's just a different way to enjoy
a part of the video it's like it's like
when you get like the veg in a bag with
your little milk and your cheese
like it's a little different way to have
it it's like oh it's you talked about
pizza it's like oh yeah i can only
eat cheese when it's on pizza like who
said that
huh who said that no that's that's the
buy this by the
way by the same logic
you're like i can't have mozzarella by
itself and why would you have mozzarella
by itself because it's [ __ ] great
it tastes good no no no no no like it's
it's like it's it's right
that's just that's not by itself god by
itself means on its own a hamburger is
not a by itself
hamburger it's not a patty by itself you
got like
potatoes you got vegetables you can put
you got
sauce you put it on a [ __ ] curry you
can put it on so many things
that just is not bread and lettuce and
tomatoes
when you have a steak and it comes with
fries is the steak by itself
what's that say that away if you order a
steak and it comes with fries
this is by itself no it's not with the
fries but i don't give a [ __ ] about the
steak
but what you're saying is is that
because it's it's like taken
out it's by it's it's not by itself or
something
what i'm trying to say is you don't have
to have steak with fries you can have
steak with a lot of other things
if if the patty is is just it's a
singular thing and there's veg next to
it the patty is by itself
that's just a fact bro what what
what you're talking about because right
that is not part of like
a burger isn't a cute like it's it's a
it's a hottie
it's a [ __ ] ingredient to a bigger
hole but you can take the ingredients
and you can do other things with the
ingredients if you have all the
ingredients of a soup next to each other
it's not a [ __ ] it it's not like you
can't just be like oh
it's not it's not by itself it's all
it's a soup what do you mean
like what are you you're chatting out of
your ass bro it's a burger
on its own just left there it's
depressing put some [ __ ] lettuce and
tomatoes and bread on that [ __ ] man
but it's on
why don't you just go to [ __ ]
mcdonald's right order a burger and just
pry it apart take the hamburger out and
eat it guys [ __ ]
patty is [ __ ] that is why that is why
it's garbage the fatty is garbage yeah
but so is this burger that you get
the the beef they give you the beef
the beef that they give you that is an
a5 beef here is pathetic
no it is so sad it's great it's like
it's a [ __ ]
grey burger as i was informed by a
friend of mine
whose whole job is to uh manage exports
of uh
meat into japan he informed me that all
the beef that isn't the top grade stuff
is just imported
well then [ __ ] him and it tastes like
[ __ ] [ __ ] him
you're adding like that reddit comment
now it's like yeah excuse me i am a beef
expert
my dad works i've heard from a friend
who works in the industry
listen when you grow up basically right
next to farms right and you get that
beef you get it fresh man
you can't give me the [ __ ] of like this
this like air sealed bag of a beef
carcass flown across a country
it tastes like [ __ ] well what if i
didn't grow up next to a [ __ ] farm
well that sucks to be used yeah go and
eat your hamburgers
by that same logic why can you still
enjoy [ __ ] mcdonald's patties
or like burgers then because that is a
burger is a great burger it's a [ __ ]
great
it's a great burger no no no no no no
it's not even the best burger in like
the fast food choice if you take a
[ __ ] burger king over at mcdonald's
burger any day of the week
it depends on the mood you're such a
liar
who would actually take away the mood
that you would actually take a
mcdonald's absolutely plastered there is
nothing more i want than double
cheeseburgers from mcdonald's
they have they have this that just
sounds like your [ __ ] prerogative
no no no but also i just think that
mcdonald's in the uk at least was like
the best fast food chain yeah probably
but there weren't many to pick from
i would say yeah yeah i don't know i
mean but there's way more to pick from
here
i mean like okay my other day i just
think okay like if you could take
a burger king burger with mcdonald's
mcdonald's fries
that would be like the perfect fast food
restaurant for me
like as it stands i either have to pick
between a shitty burger and good fries
or like a less shitty burger
and worst price i'm convinced all the
fast food places have an agreement of
who's going to have what the best
what because why do not why does not one
of them have just figured out hey
those are the good fries why don't we
get those fries you know what i mean
yeah sure but i guarantee if i
blindfolded you and i made you eat both
of them
the fries i could tell hundred percent
no we're doing it
i reckon we could you could do that with
a burger as well and you wouldn't be
able to tell oh dude i could
with with fast food chains yeah hundred
percent i can tell i'll bet my life
we gotta do them now we're gonna order
now